Thomas Fleming author of the new dealers
war where'd you get that title I got
that title over almost 50 years ago when
I was reading a letter that my boss of
that time
Fulton Hassler wrote to Upton Sinclair
the novelist azza was a very prominent
writer and editor back in the era of the
New Deal and throughout World War two
and when the war began he tried to get
into the government he wanted to work in
the office of War Information or
something like that but he was a
Republican and he got absolutely nowhere
and with great disgust he wrote to Upton
Sinclair who was trying to get him into
the government because they were very
close friends saying it's a new dealers
war there's no place in it for me and
that sort of became a lens in my mind
and I never forgot over over four
decades and it slowly emerged into what
I began to see was the focus of this
book 40 books it says you've written yes
yes I try to work on numerous projects
at the same time I write novels as well
as history books particularly historical
novels I think that makes a historian
more sensitive to the impact of history
on individual lives and it also gets you
into a phrase that has sort of become a
buzz or a word that's been sort of
become a buzzword among a historical
profession right now that's contingency
we historian is more and more are
beginning to think that history is not
inevitable and not driven by vast forces
and awful lot of it is based on
decisions that could go either way and I
think when you write historical novels
and you see people being hammered by
history that makes you even more aware
of that and a lot of this contingency
feeling I think is in the New Deal is
war you kick it off with an introduction
where you talk about FDR being important
in your New Jersey home years ago how he
was my father was a wood leader and
Frank Hague's infamous political machine
in Jersey City I don't know where if you
didn't vote Democratic you will ever get
not
ahead but we had on in the vestibule of
our house where as I say in the book a
lot of Catholics from Irish Catholics
had the Sacred Heart of Jesus
we had FDR and we virtually genuflected
to him as we went in and out he was the
god of the Democratic Party and in New
Jersey at that time and I grew up
admiring him even worshiping him but as
you get older you begin to look back on
things not through a haze of memory if
especially if you go into the business
of a historian and you start to think
well what was he really like what was
what was the whole thing all about now
that it's become so far back that we're
just right now I think we're just
getting to the end of the influence of
memory on history and and we're getting
into the pure history of World War two I
think this this book is a start in that
direction
Michael Kevin my good friend of mine
from Cornell wrote a wonderful book
called the mystic chords of memory in
which he speculates on the impact of
memory in history and he maintains that
it takes about a hundred years for
somebody to get for a generation or a
country to get to the point where they
can look back on a gigantic experience
like World War two or the Civil War
objectively you say that you spent time
with Harry Truman once yes I did
this was a very seminal experience in my
life I was invited I've selected I might
even say by President Truman that
towards the end of his life to work with
his daughter Margaret on a biography and
so I went out to independence with
Margaret and spent two weeks out there
and had lunch and dinner with the
president and his wife every day and we
talked politics we talked about
President Roosevelt we talked about
President Johnson and Henry walls and so
forth now I'm not saying that everything
that he said to me is in this book
or that you know that was the decisive
influence but I became aware of the
power of that man's personality at
different personality from Franklin D
Roosevelt what do you think he really
thought at Franklin Delano Roosevelt one
night rather late in the evening I was
sitting with the president his little
study and I said to him what did you
really think of President Roosevelt
there was a long pause and then he said
inside
he was the coldest man I ever met he
didn't seem to care about you or me or
anyone else in the world but he was a
great president he brought this country
into the 20th century now when I started
working on this book I realized a very
significant thing here was a man Harry
Truman who was senator investigated the
war effort from top to bottom and who
knew more about the inner workings of
the US war effort than anyone else in
the country and he had not one word of
praise for Franklin D Roosevelt as a
leader in World War two and I felt and I
still feel that that could be the
ultimate comment on the New Deal as war
but this was not a perfect performance
by a longshot
before we leave Harry Truman for the
moment what else did you observe about
him up close for two weeks
how old were you I was in my 40s and
this this was a 1970 and so yes I was I
was a 43 at the time and I felt uh very
strongly what you saw was what you've
got with Harry Truman he was straight
from the shoulder he told you what he
thought he wasn't a devious man and that
too as I began to study Franklin D
Roosevelt became an enormous contrast
frankly Roosevelt was anything but
straight on the shoulder he was
incredibly complex and
devious he boasted about being a
trickster a juggler who didn't let his
left hand know what his right hand was
doing and although he never quite said
this he had no hesitation whatsoever
about lying to people right to their
faces where did you find this this this
tendency to lie do you mean to be
deceitful you say he's deceitful here
yeah this well there's all there's a
whole book written titled the juggler in
which he his games he played
particularly during world war ii was
described in quite a bit of detail but
it's most visible in the diaries of
henry wallace in particular wallace was
an incredible diarist and then his oral
history which i a good deal of which i
read i think you know i would have could
have taken the rest of my life to read
it Wallace's oral history is 5,000 pages
long it's Anna Columbia University oral
history department but in those in these
diaries of Morgenthau keys and other
diarists of the Roosevelt administration
as I say particularly Wallace who was
really on to Roosevelt he seemed to be a
follower but in his diary he had a very
very tough and almost caustic attitude
towards him he called him a born water
man he could row in one direction while
looking in another of a picture in your
book of FDR and Henry Wallace what do
you see in that picture I see two men
who are both trying to express surface
admiration for each other but since I do
know what's behind those smiles what
Roosevelt had a very low opinion of
Wallace as a politician he said he
doesn't have it unquote they genocide
qua that makes a good politician and
Wallace at times during the course of
the war almost repudiated Roosevelt's
leadership at one point towards in the
middle of the war and in late 1943
Roosevelt announced that dr. New Deal
was dead he'd been retired he was a he
was okay way back in the early 30s when
they were trying to solve the Great
Depression but he was an anachronism now
and dr. when the war was in charge of
things this was a very startling
statement because the New Deal and the
Democratic Party had been very closely
identified in the minds of the voters
only about a month later Wallace was the
chief speaker at the Jackson Jefferson
Day dinner where the Democratic faithful
were real expressed their allegiance to
the ideals of the party and Wallace was
not there I should add he was ill and
Wallace said if the New Deal is dead the
Democratic Party is dead that's pretty
close to telling Roosevelt he didn't
know what he was talking about I didn't
have that figured out that the timing on
this did could you have voted for FDR uh
no I did not my first vote was for Harry
Truman interestingly I miss Bodie I was
too young to vote for FDR if he were on
the ballot today would you vote for him
it would depend a great deal on the
international situation I think it I'm
not sure I would I vote for Truman again
yes but Roosevelt I would really want to
see you know it's how things were going
in different areas and so forth because
III really accumulated a great deal
reservations about Roosevelt as a
political leader while I worked on this
book where do you live today I live in
New York and are you attached to a
school do you teach no I don't know I'm
a full-time writer and how long have you
done that since 1960 my first book was
on the Battle of Bunker Hill and by an
absolutely miraculous series of events
it became very successful and as I like
to say I started educating myself at the
public expense have you made a living
off of writing books yes I have
that and my write magazine articles I
write for mhq the quarterly Journal of
military history for American heritage
and I used to write for many other
magazines such as the New York Times
magazine which is your bestseller of all
time my most successful book was the
officers wives a novel it was published
in 1981 it's about three West pointers
and their wives who marry in 1950 and we
take the reader through the Korean and
Vietnam wars with no-holds-barred I
might add and that book was a very very
big bestseller both here and abroad how
did you train yourself to write I think
I had a gift but I got a crash course
and how to write very from my first boss
Fulton owsla he would give me a magazine
article that he had just written and
maybe with you know a lot of Corrections
in it that I had to retype and he would
explain why he made every change he
would say he would emphasize the
importance of a strong opening he would
he would explain how it would drop a
character in here knowing that later on
that character is going to play a very
powerful role later in the article and
these these this kind of advice could be
extrapolated to books to some extent but
the best advice I think that Fulton gave
me was I was really wet behind the ears
to put it mildly I was only a year out
of college I had just worked for a year
on a newspaper where'd you go to college
I went to Fordham College in New York
and I said to ousa how do you write a
book I mean the longest thing I've ever
written was a term paper at this point
and he said Tom if you saw all the food
you ate piled up in one place all the
food you ate in one year piled up in one
place you'd get sick but you don't see
it you just eat it day by day and that's
how you write a book you write four
pages a day and at the end of a year
you've got a manuscript of five or six
hundred pages now this is a big book go
back and see it's almost 700 600 yes
pages long what's the scope of it the it
it's the story of what we have forgotten
about World War two and what we never
knew and the key phrase however is that
is in the subtitle the key idea is in
the subtitle FDR and the war within
World War two
it's a narrative it's not an attack on
Roosevelt or anything like it although
some critics and some reviewers of to
have interpreted along that line it's a
narrative of this war within World War
two which is really the decline and fall
of the New Deal by the end of the war
the New Deal was kaput you have this
photograph of the headline in the
Chicago Daily Tribune FDR's
war plans what's the point of this
that's that's the story that got me into
this book I found this headline by sheer
accident back in 1986 and I started
investigating this is a really rather
incredible story this is the Chicago
Tribune that we're looking at here and
they're all the the Washington Times
Herald a sister of paper they both
published this story which was the
complete verbatim report of Rainbow five
America's secret war plan this was three
days before Pearl Harbor this was
published and it caused a gigantic
sensation people the Congress went nuts
there and the main reason they all went
nuts was because it contradicted what
Franklin D Roosevelt had publicly
promised to the American people I will
never send your boys to fight in Foreign
Wars he said that when he was running
for a third term in 1940 and he had to
say it incidentally because he was in
danger of getting beaten at that point
and yet he was in Rainbow five the plan
to send five million Americans into
Europe as an expeditionary force in 1943
and it was signed by Franklin D
Roosevelt but three days later there was
this
tremendous event which none of us have
ever forgotten the attack on Pearl
Harbor and this big leak as I call it
was completely forgotten how far did he
go and saying that he'd never send
American boys to fight on foreign soil
he he said it again and again he said it
at what time he said it in 1940 at least
three times in that campaign and but
after he got elected he began to age the
country into war with Germany not what
Japan
he wanted the Germany was that was the
country that he wanted to get us into
war with but he had painted himself into
a political corner this is one of the
fascinating things about studying after
yar he was such a completely almost too
clever for his own good you might say he
managed to persuade the people to go
along with all age short of war to the
people whom Adolf Hitler was attacking
England above all and then when he
attacked Russia we added them to our
list of of lend-lease recipients but he
had painted himself into a political
corner by saying that's all we're going
to do he did that promise of all that
that we would never send boys to fight
in Foreign Wars was never retracted and
so people began to accept well this is
how we're going to do it we're going to
supply all these guys with all the
weapons we can find and we're going to
stay out of it and the poles the really
dramatic thing was for all Roosevelt's
powers of persuasion he could not budge
these poles right up to the day before
Pearl Harbor 75 to 80 percent of the
American people said they did not want
to go to war unless Japan or Germany
attacked us you write this you say he
had seduced America into the war with
clever tricks one step forward one step
back double-talk and the last resort
provocation of Japan and then later you
say deceit had been at the heart of the
process there's no doubt about it
now is this you know there's a lot of
talk in the back and your people endorse
your books talk about revisionism yeah
are you trying to revise the way people
about FDR to some extent yes but I don't
think that I'm the first person to say
this I think I'm the first person to
integrate it into this pattern of the a
president who didn't tell the truth of
the American people who dodged to the
left dodged to the right and conducted
the war as commander-in-chief with very
very little reference to letting the
people in on crucial decisions that he
made you find it but why is this new I
mean is it
I think that what you what you do when
you write a book of this extent in this
scope you look for a pattern you try to
find the the organizing idea and the
organizing idea I think is in the title
of New Deal is war and the war within
World War two a lot of them things that
Rozsival did he did under very extreme
necessity he could not think of any way
to get us into this war with in a
straightforward way so he embargo
Japan's oil which led to a crisis in
relations between US and Japan why would
he want us in a war because he was
convinced that the future history of the
world was swinging in the balance and if
Germany won the war with Hitler with the
won the war with England and Russia they
would become so powerful that they would
really truly threaten the ability of the
United States to defend itself now a lot
of people and I quote them in the book
did not agree with this analysis we felt
a lot of the best thinkers on the
military side felt that that we had the
strength to defend ourselves whether or
not we got involved with Germany and
Japan I think that's a tough thing to
say either way at this point I focus on
the simple fact that Roosevelt thought
this way and then took steps which I
think we're not the kind of steps that
we think a president should take to
provoke another power into going to war
with us and MIT and not
I quote an editorial an editorial writer
from the from the Washington Post who
looking back on and said I wish he'd
done it in a straightforward way I wish
he'd come to the American people and
said I think the future of the world's
hanging in the balance and I think we
have to go to war with Germany Japan
will just put on the backburner but
there was no really real need for us to
go to war with Japan and everyone the
Japanese never went to war with Russia
and for a lot for several days Hitler
seriously considered not going to war
against us but Roosevelt had this streak
of deviousness he couldn't in a way he
couldn't help himself but he also had he
in the book I point this out is very
important I think to understand and why
Roosevelt did this
he was a wounded president he was
politically wounded he'd had a trauma in
1937 after he was elected by the one of
the biggest landslides in American
history for a second term he the first
thing he did was send up to the Capitol
Hill a bill to pack the Supreme Court
with seven new justices which would have
enabled him to get anything he sent up
to Congress approved by the Supreme
Court this was one of the biggest
mistakes that any president has ever
made it wrecked Roosevelt's credibility
with the American people in the
Democratic Party tore itself to shreds
the Republicans didn't have to do
anything they just sat on the sidelines
and they watched the Democrats tear each
other to shreds over this bill and in
the end Roosevelt lost he was humiliated
and as a result of that he lost
confidence in himself as a political
leader but he won in 32-36 40 and 44 he
could win elections but as we as I show
in this book his power to influence the
American people on is on particular
issues or even to control Congress
dwindled steadily and it never really
came back to the level of the first four
years and because of this trauma of the
the defeat over the Supreme Court why is
it done in every poll he's
least one two or three of all presents
in all the historians polls he he his
greatness is based I think almost
entirely on the dementia 'full way he
dealt with a great depression the
inspirational power of his oratory
particularly he was the first president
has the advantage of radio and he did
have a wonderful ability to give a great
speech and he brought those speeches
right into the home of Americans for the
first time this this gave him a power of
persuasion which was truly remarkable
but he lost confidence in that power of
persuasion if the the Supreme Court the
battle and he never really got that back
and then in the course of World War two
he made another political blunder which
really was serious in 1942 after Pearl
Harbor we had midterm elections
Roosevelt covertly announced he got ones
on with his right hand he said politics
are suspended for the rest of the war
with his left hand he was telling
everybody he could find anybody that was
against the war before Pearl Harbor
should be run out of Congress there the
first cousin to a fascist or second
cousin to a traitor and meanwhile his
vice president Henry Wallace was going
around the country saying that the goal
the war was a new deal for the world now
this was a very very dramatic statement
that shocked the living daylights out of
a lot of people and Roosevelt did not
repudiate it those two things produced a
political crisis in side the Democratic
Party and after the 1942 elections it
was scarcely a Democrat left standing in
the Midwest the Republicans made a
gigantic comeback they came with a nine
volts of seizing control of the House of
Representatives and there were all kinds
of Democrats who had no longer who no
longer loved Franklin D Roosevelt
because of the brawl of the Supreme
Court and so between the modern and
conservative Democrats and the
Republicans Roosevelt lost control of
Congress
and that's when the war within World War
2 begin I like to say that I don't like
to say it but is I guess you can say it
that from that time on Franklin D
Roosevelt political life can be summed
up in one word hell he was on the
defensive perpetually I have one chapter
in the book which is called God dimming
Roosevelt and other pastimes the
Congress has rampaged Adam they overrode
his veto so they ran a new dealers out
of all the agencies that they thought
they were going to run particularly the
OWI the office of War Information the
one that my old boss Fulton also
couldn't get in because he was a
Republican by that by the mid 1943 you
couldn't find a new dealer left and the
old NY what kind of reviews have you had
you mentioned earlier about criticism
yes can you criticize FDR today and
without being criticized yourself some
people some reviewers have found great
fault with me they are Rozsival true
believers still lists do a lot of them
out there and they also argue that to
criticize anything that Roosevelt did in
order to get us into the war against
Hitler is some kind of a model a
blindness on my part in other words he
could do anything because Hitler was
such an evil man I don't buy that kind
of reasoning to put it mildly and so I I
just I think that we we can't say
there's a wonderful line in the book
which I have a quote harry truman
towards the end of the book when we're
discussing the atomic bomb he said that
he said the Japanese are fight a war in
the cruelest most imaginable way but
because they are beasts should we be
beasts - I don't think we can play off
the morality of the enemy and say that
the that we therefore are freed from all
moral restraints and all decency in
terms of conducting political affairs of
the nation when you spent those
weeks with Terry chairman did you write
it all down I wrote some things down no
I did not run it all down but I did I
did take a pretty voluminous notes yes
why didn't you write it all well some of
it I thought was privileged material
that it was professor Truman and I were
talking just man to man and so I didn't
go put some of that down and mrs. Truman
also had some very strong political
opinions that I didn't write down
because I didn't feel that she in
particular would want me ever to publish
them or anything I never repeated them I
did tell some of the things that that
mr. Truman said in an article in
American heritage yes I did what were
some of the things let's see well I've
already told about the statement about
Roosevelt we discussed the the Vietnam
War and he was very very upset with
Lyndon Johnson he felt that Lyndon
Johnson should have taken his cue from
Lincoln who was a mr. Tom Warner mr.
Truman's heroes of course and also mr.
Truman was so historically minded and he
felt that Johnson should have run for
president in 1968 and decided as Lincoln
did in nineteen in 1864 decided once and
for all whether the public was behind
the war or they weren't and he felt that
Johnson by chickening out and not
running had done more harm to the
presidency he thought than any man since
James Buchanan what about mrs. Truman
who did what was hurt what were her
strongest use about she took some very
strong said some very strong things
about Franklin Roosevelt she did not
admire him that that I'm perfectly I'm
willing to say I wouldn't want to quote
her but but she was a very very astute
politician she was intimately connected
with so many of mr. Truman's decisions
and I think that she was on the inside
of the way that mr. mr. Roosevelt dealt
with mr. Truman there was a famous quote
which is public quote in which she said
when when Franklin D
will died she said this is a terrible
this will be a terrible load on Harry
Roosevelt has told him nothing now a lot
of people back then and even since have
interpreted this as a fear her fear that
mr. Truman would not be adequate for the
job that he was about to take having
gotten to know mrs. Truman rather well I
think anything that was anything but the
case that was her expression of her real
anger at Franklin D Roosevelt for the
way he kept Truman at arm's length he
did not want Harry Truman as his vice
president and he made that very clear by
giving him no responsibilities only
talking to him twice after they got
elected and for just two little brief
conversations in which he told them
absolutely nothing we Truman didn't even
know that we had an atomic bomb for
instance which was one of the best-kept
secrets she suggested stong dude what
Stalin did know yes because that's
another chapter in the book I call it
red star rising we now know thanks to
the release of the Venona transcripts
which are decrypts of of cables that the
KGB exchanged with their agents in
America we now know that the Stalin had
329 agents inside Roosevelt's
administration a pretty startling number
and we also know that Roosevelt had been
warned about this at least twice and he
dismissed it completely he just didn't
want to hear about it
329 yes and what did people that
defended or were critical back in those
days of Whitaker chambers or McCarthy
Ollie what do they say today about this
I think that the only defense that they
have left now is that well we don't
really they don't really seem to have
any heavy evidence that they gave away
any crucial secret which is Retta
laughable since they did steal the
atomic bomb but IIIi really haven't I've
avoided arguments with that side of the
of the literary and political community
I might say but I think that what I want
more interested in this
is how Roosevelt's politics at home led
to international decisions that had
really big impact on the conduct of the
war in this respect I think that his
recognition of Soviet Russia back in
1933 led him to feel he was locked in he
Russell was a man who never wanted to
admit he'd made a mistake that's in
henry wallace's diary and other Diaries
and he felt locked in to this connection
with the Soviet Union and he absolutely
just didn't want to admit that there was
anything wrong with anything they did
one of the most glaring examples of this
is the Katyn massacre this was a story
that exploded in 1943 the Germans found
in the Katyn forest in eastern Poland
the bodies of 9,000 Polish officers that
had been murdered
they said by the Russians the British
had created a commission to study this
because they had the Polish government
in exile in London and they had to do
something and they concluded that the
Russians did it that state these men had
been murdered by Stalin's order but they
could not get Roosevelt to read this
report it's just simply ignored it he
just didn't want to hear about it and
when one of his top intelligence people
a man named George Earl who was a navy
it was a Navy officer he was stationed
in Ankara Turkey Turkey and he was
really getting all kinds of intelligence
out of the Balkans and Central Europe he
became convinced that the kid that the
Katyn was it was a Stalinist crime and
he came home and told Roosevelt this
toward the end of the war and rosal said
it's German propaganda I don't want to
hear anything about it and when Earl
said I want to publish an article to
alert the American people to the kind of
ally we have Rozsival issued a written
order saying you are in effect saying
you are still a member of the US Navy
and I forbid you
say one word about this and the next day
Earl was transferred to Samoa for the
rest of the war
we never did hear anything about the
Katyn massacre anything worth mentioning
and every day we were few there were a
few Polish American radio stations who
tried to broadcast information about it
they were visited by the FBI and told if
you don't want to lose your license
you're going to stop saying this as you
know you use a lot of the diary of Henry
Wallace yes like where do you find them
the henry wallace's diaries are there a
lot of them have been published edited
by John Blauman very very superb book
and the price of vision it's called and
I found that book absolutely invaluable
for writing this book and so there I've
also as I say to spend a good deal of
time looking at the Wallace's oral
history at Columbia let me jump into the
middle of the book chapter nine yes fall
of a prophet yes only because it just
shows I'm I kept way as I was reading it
kept thinking could this happen today
it isn't in this atmosphere people the
names I mean Henry Wallace's and their
Jesse Jones yes he was the head of the
Secretary of Commerce and head of the
reconstruction Finance Corporation a
very powerful and conservative Democrat
who was also an extremely close friend
of Franklin Roosevelt's Milo Perkins
Milo Perkins was the man who really ran
the the agency that Wallace
theoretically headed the BEW you have a
whole scenario here on Milo Perkins that
I just wonder what would happen if this
happened today and how public was at
that yeah well it became public because
the Washington Times Herald who had who
had supported Russell first incidentally
for a third term
rosal if we could could we make a
parenthesis here a very good example of
Roosevelts I think bad political
judgment during World War two was the
sister of the woman excuse me
the brother of the woman who ran the
Times Herald Cissy Patterson her name
was was Joe Patterson who ran the Daily
News the biggest newspaper in America at
the time the New York Daily News
two million circulation he had opposed
Roosevelt and he supported Rozsival for
a third term too but it posed his
attempt to get us into the war when
Pearl Harbor exploded Patterson came
rushed to Washington he'd been in World
War one and he came into the Oval Office
and he said he wanted to volunteer for
the war effort to do something and
Roosevelt wouldn't even speak to him he
kept signing things for a while and then
finally said what can I do for you Joe
they know each other extremely well and
Joe said mr. president want to get into
the war and Roosevelt said you know what
you can do you can go back and read
those editorials that you wrote for the
last six months GAD condemning me as a
war monger and he read that on for 15
minutes and literally reduced this
strong man to tears
Patterson rushed from the Oval Office to
the office of the Washington Times
Herald and he and his sister [ __ ]
jointly vowed as I say in the book to
make Franklin D Roosevelt life miserable
for the rest of his days on earth and
they did as much as they could
what was their connection to the Chicago
Tribune they were cousins of mr.
mcCormick the birdie McCulloch who ran
the Chicago Tribune they were all part
of this sort of extended family and the
Tribune had published that original
rainbow to be accomplished the rainbow
fog yes yes back to Milo Perello perkins
is a good example go ahead I just want
to read a headline for the Washington
Times Herald and what time of the of the
Roosevelt administration's would this at
a ban this is mid-1943 Milo the Messiah
of Mystic Washington yeah
Milo Perkins high priest of his own
mystic cult yeah Milo Perkins was a a
they call him liberal Catholics in those
days he he was a new age
I guess you'd say as I say he was
Wallace's right-hand man but he really
had this cosmic desire to it there's
even a letter that I quote in the book
that he wrote when he first came in the
government that his chief desire was to
quotes save the world and he by almost
by definition he was an extremist and he
was the man who really triggered this
argument or public quarrel between Henry
Wallace and Jesse Jones about who was
going to control the economics of this
board of economic warfare that was
buying all kinds of raw materials in
South America and in Africa and Jones
wanted the key it was Washington turf
war basically you know familiar to
anybody in the capital but it just got
completely out of hand the two men
started calling each other horrible
names in public and Jones was egging
Wallace on and very often writing a lot
of the things that he was saying and
Wallace was vice president and Wallace
was vice president but he also had this
as I say very important job which
enabled him to go to South America for
instance and make a triumphant tour from
one end of this of the continent to the
other because he just spent six hundred
million dollars buying raw materials
down there and in in part of his program
to push the New Deal for the world he
insisted on paying the highest
imaginable prices and in anyone had put
into the contracts the fact that more
money would go to the workers than
ordinarily the employers paid them he
was really doing a lot of things that
upset the State Department extremely so
anyway this this tremendous clash it
kept coming and coming and coming and
and finally Roosevelt issued a order no
more arguments I won't I can't stand
stand it but Milo Perkins could not
control himself and he gave a speech at
the board of economic warfare with had
3,000 employees and he just lost it
coming here and yet he basically ran it
for Wallace it was spinning you know
Wallace had a preside over the Senate
and he was doing a lot of other things
and so while it was really Milo's agency
and as I say he just lost
and he proceeded to start it all over
again attacking Jesse Jones as a
slimeball and this and that and so forth
and there was a reporter in the crowd or
maybe some member of the board of
economic warfare who didn't like Milo
too much immediately got to a phone and
call The Washington Times Herald and
they had meanwhile been accumulating all
this dope about Milo being a liberal
Catholic who had his own little private
Church down in Houston they used to meet
in his attic and so they put they they
put out this cartoon in the inlet in The
Washington Times Herald of Milo up in
the attic stirring this pot of mystic
brew and while sustaining and looking
like a sort of dazed nincompoop staring
at this but the story was all about how
Milo had started the argument over again
and all the names he called Jesse Jones
and so forth and that was it
Rozsival fired Wallace dissolved the
Board of economic warfare and of course
fired Milo Perkins - it was as I call it
a public defense stration of the Vice
President of the United States what
happened to Jesse Jones Jesse Jones
remained in power at the he lost a
little bit of the control the money side
of his the board of economic warfare
operations they merged that into another
entity but that that that this feud
continued and after Roosevelt was
elected for a fourth term he tried to
pay Wallace off or reward Wallace for
supporting the ticket in 1944 he fired
Jones and tried to give Wallace the job
of Secretary of Commerce and head of the
reconstruction Finance Corporation which
controlled billions and billions of
dollars and this this is a president
just won a full term this I attempt to
do this was rejected by the House of
Representatives by a vote of 400 to 1
give you an idea have little power
Franklin D Roosevelt had real real power
he could get elected but his his the the
movement that brought him to
power and I quote a very very potent new
dealer in this book a guy named Ben
Cohen the the movement that the New Deal
had fallen apart there's no two ways
about there's another couple of people
in the administration who work side by
side and there's a photograph of the two
of them and the reason I bring it up is
because there's some present-day
connections here here is Cordell Hall on
the left and Sumner Welles on the right
more Dale halls job in the FDR
administration he was Secretary of State
and Sumner Welles was Undersecretary of
State
number two there number two men in a
department they cordially hated each
other in fact they hated each other so
intensely that the door between their
two offices they were side by side in a
state department was locked they never
spoke Welles was was a the man that
Rozsival prefer to do business with he
was number two he was the number two guy
but he had been a tendon that
Roosevelt's wedding as a very young man
and Roosevelt had sponsored his career
in the Foreign Service he was a Groton
man just like Roosevelt and so forth and
so whereas Hall had been brought in to
mollify
the southerner the southern wing of the
Democratic Party he was a former senator
from Tennessee so uh they really
intensely disliked it but the reason I
bring it up today is that Cordell Hull
being from Tennessee was a friend of Al
Gore's senior yes and I think he's is he
not respected very much by Al Gore jr. I
think he is everybody from Tennessee at
immense respect for Cordell Hall he was
an icon of the well among all the
southern senators southern border state
senators and you could not touch him and
Rozsival actually made fun of him behind
his back he this is the typical
Roosevelt touch Rosa Hall had a slight
Lisp and he was always talking about
free trade that was his one issue and
Rosalee is to make fun of him saying yes
we must have more free trade and Sumner
Welles son Ben Wells wrote for the New
York Times the other book about a very
good book about his father yes so what
were their politics of the two of them
one one conservative one liberal
one was certainly more liberal than the
other that's no doubt about it but in in
the chapter that I bring the two of them
together in this book there was a crisis
inside the State Department when the
Russian ambassador went to Joseph Davies
who had been a former ambassador to
Russia and told him that the government
of the Soviet Union was losing
confidence in the American government
and they had to be something had to be
done about it and he blamed it on the
State Department officials who were
hostile to the Soviet Union he was
talking about the Russian experts in the
State Department George Kennan Charles
beau and Lloyd Enderson and several
other people who had been specially
trained and were a cadre of people who
really knew what was going on inside the
Soviet Union this president basileus
said to Davies who then immediately
rushed to Harry Hopkins to tell him this
Harry Hopkins being Roosevelt's
right-hand men and the ultimate New Deal
or as I call him in the book and told
him we got to do something so Welles was
called in and told you got to get rid of
these guys this was an incredible crisis
because Welles really ran the State
Department and he knew that if he
allowed the Soviet ambassador to force
him to fire these men that his name
would be mud with Cordell Hull it much
more than it already was and it exposed
him to the most awful counter-attack and
he was vulnerable on a very very sad but
a serious point he was a bisexual and he
had had several homosexual episodes
which were semi public knowledge but
Wells back in those times yes they were
semi public they they were circulating
around Washington anybody published him
in the newspaper nobody had as yet
published in the newspaper but there
were a numerous people who were
threatening to publish them at this
point this is well but about Wells yes
and all knew about them and
when so Wells had to make really the
most agonizing decision of his life so
he tried to compromise to some extent
but he did fire two of these guys and
Ryoga and it Louie Henderson was
probably the toughest of the the Russian
experts he was sent to Iraq
how's that for shipping he knew
absolutely nothing about Iraq he was
sent to this utter backwater on the
say-so of the Russian ambassador this
this torrent for as far as a home was
concerned he felt that Wells had
betrayed the Foreign Service and and so
Wells had to go and he said we went to
Roosevelt and he said it's either me or
Wells and if if you insist on wells
I just might leak this to the newspaper
about his homosexuality so Roosevelt
with great great reluctance how to allow
Wells to resign and this was the nadir
this was late 1943 and this was the
moment when Roosevelt lost all control
of the State Department Wells was his
guy in there and this was the whole
issue of who control the State
Department is very very important than
this book this photograph was taken when
that photograph was taken in and in the
fall of 1944 it's a rain spattered face
that you're looking at there Franklin D
Roosevelt is riding through New York and
a freezing cold downpour a northeast
storm he's running for a fourth term and
he's trying to prove to the people that
he's not a fatally ill man he managed to
do this although it's a miracle that he
did it his doctors thought he would die
we now know what was it he was extremely
sick by in early 1944 he was examined by
a heart specialist and they found that
he could die at the doctor dr. Harvey
Bruin found that he could die at any
and they restricted him to to keep him
alive
dr. Bruin restricted him to a 20-hour
week now the President of the United
States the leader of a global wall was
told he could only work 20 hours a week
how would he do that
he slept very late and got to the Oval
Office only about 11 o'clock in the
morning would see a few visitors then
would have lunch take a long nap come
back to the Oval Office for another two
hours
in other words work about four hours a
day five days a week and that was
supposed to be it what kind of shape was
he in and turan and what was the meeting
all about and then also Yalta at Tehran
and he was as far as we know and still
fairly good shape although he had a an
episode at Tehran in which in the midst
of a dinner
he turned green and faltered and lost
consciousness in his chair and had to be
rushed back to his room and it was there
at the dinner Stalin Churchill and a
whole slew of aides it was very very
upsetting episode and after that when he
came back from Tehran he was definitely
a very sick man and that was when they
had this physical examination which led
them to put him on a 20-hour work week
that was when what year this was 1944
early 1944 and that was when Ben Cohen
the most brilliant of the New Deal as I
think he was a really brilliant lawyer
who wrote the Securities Exchange Act he
was working in the East Wing of the
White House during the war and he wrote
an eight-page memorandum which I found
in the files of the Roosevelt library in
which he begged Rozsival not to run
again he told him as I already said the
Coalition had collapsed but he was
really saying too that he wasn't up to
the judge you'll find that on your own
or had you read about in another book I
had heard about it and I had a very good
researcher who was assisting me at the
Roosevelt library he found it for me yes
what about Yalta what kind of shape was
that I think I've got a let me make sure
I get the right yeah this is the elta
photograph roosevelt was he mustered all
his dwindling energy for Yalta and
there's no really hard evidence that he
was non compos mentis or anything like
that but you can see the impact of this
a tremendous effort that he made there
went on the ship home Sam Rosenman who
was this top speechwriter and inside
Oval Office aide he spent the entire
voyage home trying to get Rozsival to
talk about the speech that he was going
to give to Congress about Yalta and
Rozsival just sat there like a zombies
staring into space for the entire voyage
you have a photograph the last one that
was taken of him that's the last picture
that was taken of Roosevelt yes down in
Warm Springs it was taken the day he
died and that is a very heartbreaking
picture to look at old is here he was 63
I believe I'm not too good on the you
but you paint a picture in your book
that he didn't like get along with
Winston Churchill he he he did not get
along with him as well as the war
progress they started out as best of
friends but really Roosevelt was very
hostile to the idea of continuing the
British Empire and when he got to the
summit conferences with Churchill and
Stalin he shifted the balance of his
attention completely to Stalin and left
Churchill as definitely a a weak third
party in the whole discussion and
Churchill really never forgave him for
that where do you find this kind of
information this is in many many records
of these particularly one of the best
sources I had was a Charles Bolin's
memoirs he was one of the into one of
the Russian experts at the State
Department and was the what was
Roosevelt's interpreter at Tehran and at
Yalta and his memoirs are extremely
penetrating and very critical of
Rozsival how long did you work on this
book I worked on it off and on since
1986 when I started working on that
article the big
leek which I wrote for American heritage
as a was published at American heritage
and off and on over the next 15 years I
would go back to it as I found more
information or more insights into it and
then for about two years before it went
to press I worked on a full time when
you write where do you write I write in
my own apartment in New York or up on a
little attic room in my Connecticut
house with an air-conditioner buzzing
away and I usually work about four to
six hours a day
I'm do you start early I regard it as a
job you get up at 8 o'clock and you
should be at work by a quarter to 9:00
there's no doubt about it and writing
for you is on a scale of 1 to 10 is it
10 being easy 1 being very hard it
varies from book to book a great deal
some books I have I wrote 1776 year of
illusions of also a sort of expose of
what was going on in that crucial year
that took me seven years to write and
that was agony I had so many so much
heavy research and so much revisions
this book was not in the final push
because they had accumulated so much
material this book was not such a hard
book to write I I felt this was a book
another thing that is always important
to me because I'm I guess of something
of a mystic like alright as a I felt
this was a book I was born to write this
was this the seeing that epic that that
phrase the New Deal is war so early in
my writing career and spoken by the man
who was my might say my literary mentor
it just gave me a feeling of momentum
that that drove me through this book and
made it I think of a very strong
narrative so what do you think so far
from what you've seen the reaction to
the book I think that people are
on the whole startled by it I don't
think that the complete reaction is
sinking in as yet III think that this is
a book that's going to have to be
absorbed by people who won't then talk
about it to each other and but I think
in the long run it's it's going to be
accepted as a as I say a first step
towards looking beyond the memories of
World War two into the history of reason
your biggest critic so far hmm a
reviewer in The Wall Street Journal
didn't like the book at all he he
thought that I was simply anti Roosevelt
and he really I would rather upset by
that review he distorted what I said
characters from The Wall Street Journal
yes yes I know it's rather shocking if
you can get knocked there you can get
knocked anywhere I said I guess you'd
say when you're writing a book this
critical or Franklin D Roosevelt what
are your politics today my politics I'm
a registered Democrat a Truman Democrat
I guess you'd say and what does that
mean that means that I think I'm a
moderate when it comes to political to
devoting and and political thinking but
I really don't think that my politics
has anything to do with my writing I try
to keep that completely out of my
writing I feel that the historian should
have no political opinions whatsoever do
you have another book you're working on
already yes I'm working on a memoir of
my father the wood boss from Jersey City
and it's going to be quite quite a
different look at how American politics
takes place like I should say what years
ed come here uh well I hope it'll come
out in a year or so or maybe maybe a
little bit more and your son Richard had
something to do with your book yes yes
oh he's my favorite researcher he's a
he's a Russian specialist here that ms
and in Russian history from the Russian
department at Columbia and a real
computer was till he's been a great help
to me this is the cover of the book it's
called the new dealers war and our guest
has been Thomas Fleming thank you very
much for joining us thank you